do you know what they want
[Music]
they want chocolate that has not been
trans forget about transiting the kids
forget about transiting the adults
people want regular old chocolate they
want
she her chocolate that's just regular
chocolate they want hee him chocolate
that contains nuts and that's what they
got from Jeremy's chocolates you you may
have seen this this commercial I I've
had a very busy few weeks I'm traveling
a lot and so I came into the office did
my show I went off-site to record a long
interview for a project we're working on
I came back I had to record more that
night as I'm recording I hear a pause
they say stop Michael you got to walk
out of the set Jeremy needs you so I'm
in the middle of doing my I said Jeremy
needs you I say okay fine I walk out and
Jeremy Jeremy says hey I need you to
stand here next to the McLaren so why is
that he goes oh we started a chocolate
company it's it's called Jeremy's
chocolates you go to ihatehersheys.com
because Hershey's is translating the
chocolates and we want to give people an
alternative I said okay yeah that makes
sense so we do that we shoot the
commercial it comes out immediately this
is like the same day that Hershey's
pushed its weird trans campaign where to
celebrate women's history month or
whatever women's month it is they got a
dude dressed up as a woman to sell the
chocolate so Jeremy puts it up
immediately I hate hershey's.com goes up
immediately sources the chocolate
immediately and you think okay it's a
funny joke but are they actually going
to sell any chocolate
Jeremy has sold 300 000.
non-woke chocolate bars the man has
become
actually Willy Wonka he is now he's
always been Willy wonka-esque he is now
literally Willy Wonka 300 000 chocolate
bars in less than two days
I hate hersheys.com go order yours check
out the commercial
International women's day is upon us
again
and I love an international woman but
our friends over at Hershey's they don't
even know what a woman is they've hired
a biological male to be the spokesperson
for their women's day campaign and
they're calling that campaign and I
swear I'm not making this up her she
Hershey it's humiliating and it's the
reason that I'm launching
Jeremy's chocolate we have two kinds
she her
and he him
one of them's got nuts if you need me to
tell you which one it is
keep giving your money to Hershey's but
if you're tired of giving your money to
woke corporations that hate you and
you're looking for a delicious chocolate
bar from a company that actually wants
your business head over to
ihatehersheys.com and Order Jeremy's
chocolate today
if you ask me I think people are hungry
for an alternative and I think you've
all proved that so head on over to
ihatehersheys.com and get yourself some
delicious non-work chocolate and just
keep us all laughing because these lips
they overplay their hands and they think
that they've got total power and they
think we're all gonna cave and this goes
right up to what we were talking about
at the top of the show they are so
certain that we're gonna cave they are
so certain that we're going to Cave that
whenever anyone stands up against their
insane agenda
they will libel that person they'll
smear that person they they really think
oh we can cancel anybody we want
we can silence anybody we want we're
going to put out a crappy product and
you're gonna buy it because you have no
Alternatives you you sheep you little
sheep you'll do what I say where'd Dr
faucy come from I don't know that's
their voice that's what they believe
and what we say is
no
no whatever products you poison we're
gonna offer an alternative whatever
crazy ideas you say are inevitable we're
going to stand firm and you're gonna
have to deal with it Libs
people want a choice they don't want an
echo
that was a great line from Phyllis
Schlafly it is a line that I quoted in
my CPAC speech and it is a
it's an important fact of conservatism
we are if we're just going to be
fighting for the the liberal policies of
10 years ago then there's no point in
having conservatives if we're just going
to be to use Michael malice's term
progressives driving the speed limit
then there's no point to having
conservatives okay we need to say no
stand firm and actually go on the
offense go back in the other direction
Sometimes the best defense is a strong
offense
the squishes will not do
on that point by the way I think YouTube
may have taken down my CPAC speech if
you want to read the full text verbatim
you got to go to dailywire.com I have it
up there
you can read what the media it won't
won't allow you to see or what they'll
just lie about in their in their print
people don't want the squishes and so
there was a guy who's a big swish
governor in Maryland and he was
considering running for president
Larry Hogan not looking good
it was a tough decision but I've decided
that I will not be a candidate for the
Republican nomination for president
wow huge news here I'm going to make
news that's just as big I too will not
be a candidate in 2024 for the
Republican nomination for president I am
constitutionally ineligible because I'm
too young and yet I think I had a much
better chance of winning that nomination
and the presidency than Larry Hogan ever
did
what's the lane for Larry Hogan
hey I'll be a liberal from 2019.
hey I'll be I'm a liberal but not the
craziest fringiest liberal that you ever
saw now if I'm going to vote for a
Democrat I want to vote for a real
Democrat I want to I want a clear
alternative if I'm going to vote for a
liberal I want him to be a coherent
liberal and if I want a conservative I
want a conservative people want Clarity
and I think a lot of the times the
squishes believe that what we need to do
is we just need to be a little
conciliatory meet you halfway okay
all right you guys want to trans the
three-year-olds I don't think I think we
should only translate 18 year olds okay
let's meet at 12. no if you keep if you
keep meeting halfway and halfway and
halfway as they push to the left then
you're just inevitably going to follow
them all the way down the road to
Perdition
now speaking of people who might run for
president
and speaking of Ambiguously partisan
people
Senator Joe manchin Democrat from West
Virginia
is asked if he will endorse Joe Biden in
2024 here is his answer
are you going to endorse Joe Biden if he
runs for reelection oh there's plenty of
time for the election this is the
problem with America right now we start
an election every time there's a cycle
he's the leader of your party I I
no the bottom line is let's see who's
involved let's wait until we see who all
the players are let's just wait until it
all comes out my main purpose right now
is to work from our country and my in my
state that's my responsibility I'm not
going to make my announcement for
anything until the end of the year
you've said you're not running for
president is that an open question
though I didn't say that I didn't say
anything about that I the bottom line is
I will make my political decision in
December whatever it may be to run for
president taking anything off the table
and I'm not put and I'm not putting
anything on the table I said I'll make a
decision in Jan at this at the end of
this year
so Joe manchin is recognizing here
one
maybe he wants to run for president so
he's trying to keep his options open but
he's in a tough spot he's going to run
in the Democratic party he'd never win
the nomination is he going in the
running the Republican Party he'd have a
better shot at winning the nomination
but no is he going to run as an
independent that's probably going
nowhere could he try to make a play to
be a vice president or that's I don't
think that's going to happen remember
John McCain wanted to pick Joe Lieberman
the Democrat to be his running mate
Republicans would have completely thrown
him out for that it's absurd to have
your party pick a member of the opposite
party to be the running mate and and so
I don't see that ever happening or is
Joe manchin trying to keep his powder
dry get ready to cross the aisle endorse
whoever the eventual Republican nominee
is whether that's Trump whether that's
Ron DeSantis whether that's somebody
else
and then get a position like I don't
know Secretary of State or some cabinet
position that to me seems more likely
he's trying to
he's trying to keep his powder dry to
aim at something that would be pretty
significant in a republican
Administration which is probably where
he would get it
he also realizes Joe Biden is just not a
good bet right now and the people don't
want that the member block begins now
head on over it's music Monday baby and
I am going to put all of my
uh cultural Maven focus and prudence and
insight
towards some new song go to
dailywire.com Knowles use code Knowles
kwl-e-s at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans we'll see you there
[Music]
thank you